right
Jesus man sorry dude I was texting with
uh um you got that Wesley Snipes no I
was just texting with uh Jesus Christ
just hit me up do you know what he say
I'm not white
he says come back oh cool I said we no
we're just kind of kind of waiting here
waiting here Sunday's coming up on this
coming up Oh get Cadbury eggs up the
kazoo let's go here bud so yeah man you
do it man I'm at the Houston Jersey bro
oh thank you man there's a friend of my
back is that Nolan Ryan nope Oh Rat King
number 80 wyden number 80 this year
you're born at dawn El Rey uh I'm not
sure some guy who's in um some guy who
had just gotten a sober liver detox drop
this off at the Houston improv oh that's
dope
he's like dude I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] have the
Jersey I was like yeah it's really cool
man really really cool so how were the
fight your first UFC experience dude I
saw you back there yelling get in there
yeah you know I singled you out cuz I
saw [ __ ] Santino's red air Oh how's
it go clear steel Santino is just I mean
you could see him from a million miles
away he's kind of like one of those road
flares that people put out when there's
an accident just [ __ ] bright red yeah
it's just like yeah just his spray of
violent red - did you have fun at the
fight skate it was crazy man bro I
couldn't well a couple times I called
the police I was like your kid yeah I
was like just two men that will not stop
fighting hey you know I was like yeah
during the one I was like there's a
black guy that keeps hitting this
Mexican guy okay stop will not stop stop
kick him in the leg don't do anything
about it
I said salt there's one guy that keeps
stopping up
the cop went sir weary I'm at a UFC Fan
I miss my State Farm arena brother okay
and you guys should be down here there's
a couple of you buddies around here just
milling around about to fire a gun at
one of these guys was it it was crazy
more violent or less flatten these would
like going in what do you think you're
gonna see because I told you I might now
listen watch on TVs one thing
seeing it in person especially we have
Rogan seats it's it's intense Oh
first of all you feel like you're in the
back of her like Rogen is driving you
somewhere near in the back in the year
in the back of his car you did like
you're his kids you're like just six
antisocial Studios ride like Rogan
experience do I cheer do I not am I
being good to ask that for popcorn what
do I do you know and Rogen's up there
eating rare meat he's eating [ __ ]
cheetah limbs and you know whatever else
drinking the blood you know you get a
little somebody will bringing a tray of
blood from [ __ ] to bed between rounds
TRT yeah bro how much he works during
the fight is pretty crazy like I
couldn't even for five hours I couldn't
even communicate had one moment of
communication non-stop yeah cuz he like
does the thing and then runs into the
ring to do the interview runs out he's
the best ever do it yeah I mean he just
it just doesn't stop he's real seamless
oh did you meet DC no he's from
Louisiana I know I know I thought by the
time I got to maybe meet him it was the
end of the night and I just felt like
he's probably pretty tired like to see
though he's a great day oh man I'm even
a huge fan dude you were crunk about
Poirier
oh poor a [ __ ] what is happening
right why still acting like you know I
was head your little flat tits all
[ __ ] up you hide your shorts oh my god
it's the dardan it's the daughter what
are you watching you guys watch your
instrument video
I think yeah I saw dusting like this
yeah cool man you'd even know you he's
like alright yeah thanks handsome lady I
did I did feel like I did there was a
point where I just that felt like a lot
lizard I mean cuz I am now I use the
terms you can't use it this episode okay
burden could be anything like yeah this
lady made me a sandwich like there's
like all these lot lizards it blew my
mind man it blew my mind how I woke up
actually two nights ago I woke up and
watch the fight again on YouTube and
it's good right yeah and it was nothing
compared to how insane it was in person
it gave me a different respect for four
fighters like just the fact that it's
like just to come out round after round
like sometimes the round would be ending
and I'm like oh my god I got three more
yeah and you could see they were kind of
like elated the round was any because
they were tired but they don't like dude
you just minute you have to come right
back five minutes and guys whoopin your
ass right back the principal is not
going to come out and stop some say it's
the worst job in the world depends each
octave yeah um but yeah I was excited
for dustman I think like great story
yeah it was a great story and and just
to see max Holloway I mean his
confidence dude he kept finding both of
them just kept fighting they could have
fought all night I bet that's crazy for
your first fight you got those two
fights as a main event co-main event
you're lucky really yes super lucky yeah
sometimes gonna be a bummer but yummy
well Brandon Davis came out right in the
beginning the first fight on the prelims
and those guys beat the [ __ ] out of each
other I felt like they were just like
it's almost spouse it'll be like I
couldn't tell who the woman was but
there was a lot of spousal there's a lot
going on of do domestic violence blood
everywhere so
I needed a blood transfusion he was
standing by the ring with his mouth open
and he [ __ ] caught a couple pints and
then he went on it's typo you know he
looked great when he left
um but yeah that fight was and that was
the first one that was you know is there
wasn't even that many people there at
that point if he would come late go to
fight in Vegas people don't show up to
the main event it's so disrespectful
like watch a fight in Vegas usually
you'll see like behind Rogan empty empty
empty then like by the third card on the
main card you know by the third fight
people start filling in I'm like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah they just wait for
that main event did I keep Hollywood
[ __ ] yeah it was hot like Shaq came at
about with about maybe three fights left
damn Shaquille boys he's such a hassle
yeah we come to watch three fights I
know you like to shock us in front of
you bro oh he's sat in front of somebody
down in Dallas Page oh that makes sense
yeah but Diamond Dallas is that yoga so
he just can't Dallas does that yoga but
he also can't see anyways yes eyes are a
little like you know those dogs with
cataract that's what Diamond Dallas Page
so he just has no idea he thought fight
was going on staring at Shaq's if I
could nap I think it's about Shaq's neck
was fight as I dam it's only black guys
on this car yeah it's all black car no
it's cool it's like pray preview he's
just pray and he can see anything dude I
had Steven Seagal sitting from two girls
in he's big dude he's a chef yeah we're
some [ __ ] clothes and I was with a
bunch of USC fighters and so we go
someone say so Kate kept standing up the
chin and we couldn't see and this was in
Toronto so I'm gonna say something
shopping I'm like I want to say some you
just say something like plus you me and
I go sit down like this he turned around
I was like I was so scared why would you
say hey Steven uh we're just gonna try
to enjoy the fight live a better do you
mind just trying to sit down sighs I
didn't want to get a death touch to the
neck bro I've seen in his videos in
Russia just [ __ ] chopping dudes I
didn't want that dude he beat up 19 guys
on a shady cruise ship and Russia like
40 years no good he's still posting
shitty City and yet the yellow glasses
on the squinty little eyes ma'am
yeah double chin okay he's getting big
dude it looks like he just recently
bought Emeril Lagasse - it looks like he
could maybe beat him really gassy we
took the ladle on the same and we're all
scared of Cup but dude definitely
different gave me like a little bit of a
different respect for you money do oh
yeah you do I mean I want about a grand
yeah and that was no district but
disrespect against does it was fun for
us
sure was it yeah guy sure they try to
give money to cut your hair they didn't
believe in you Dustin okay yeah [ __ ]
does this on the show tomorrow your bet
$1,000 that you didn't believe it no I
believe in max Holloway bro it's look
and I believe in max Holloway and then
you don't you don't believe max Holloway
that's why you took the bet you son of a
[ __ ] max hope you're watching it is
what it is bro forty dollars
I think forty fifty we did make it fifty
and I put 300 on Poirier online no I
don't believe that
yep so sports betting AG but duty
definitely I can't believe used to do
that either bro what were you doing out
there I had no other idea I don't know
I'll just run it around like a chicken
my head cut off and just [ __ ] huge
why my thing call the cops why get out
in the cut lick you all right and then I
never got paid well yeah that's oh that
was another thing that I felt man bro no
joke I don't get like bad vibes around
that many people but Dana White
I mean I'm Gravas grateful to be it as a
van I know it's their business but
somebody should start a different
company or something and I mean it just
the bad juju dude it's bad have you ever
been around a promoter just feels dirt
it felt dirty you know it smells like
when you're around like a drug dealer a
little bit yeah you're just like mmm I
just feel it's like a darkness I don't
care if the drug dealer have you know
coke and a little bit of aspirin but if
he only got coke and he's not trying to
help at all either and yes just getting
you hooked if you don't have that
Tylenol PM
yeah it just seemed like
I just didn't trust him you know that
was a thing I don't know him and maybe
they'll shoot oh yeah should you so I
should be a fighter yeah that's a thing
he controlled he'd already seemed like
to me was a slave owner and a weird
that's exactly what it is its executives
and nondescript note and I'm no color to
slaves you know or anything like that
but just that the worldwide slave trader
and I feel like there's a better way it
felt to me like business-wise which I'm
- look I don't know [ __ ] anything I
got beat up by Brad Castleman when I was
in [ __ ] sixth grade and then this
other guy who ended up being a cop who I
think ended up beating some people you
know it hit me a couple times in math
class or something still counts though
you know yeah yeah I'm over - but dude I
did fall off a [ __ ] roof one time
when I was painting and land on a guy
and he got knocked out that counts so
that's - I'm one call to DDT a country
DDT Road he got paint in his [ __ ]
eyes but yeah what's on that he was
never the same after that but I say he
was never the same before the hey what's
up now bro yeah it's this weird business
dude yeah it just felt a dirty business
but that's what like but in the ring
there's nothing you know I don't know I
don't know how you beat let me ask you
this there and then this is too serious
for this type of podcast when you watch
it what Dustin went through and max
Holloway went through how much do you
think they should have made that night
when you watched what style bender and
Kelvin gasps oh when through oh my god
Kelvin Gastelum that guy fought
basically the usain bolt of [ __ ] UFC
in board shorts in board shorts he's a
small Mexican dude dude ace they should
have let him be on a horseback or
something up there against least give
him a chainsaw yeah give him a boat
paddle or something like give him some
weapon Jesse it's unfair they let that
guide you and bro he was fearless how
tough is he under if to me he was the
toughest guy of the night by far
correct the tongue stopping stuff as
well I dude between mags II dusted I got
a style bender oh [ __ ] Eric Anders
got lit the [ __ ] up against Khalil
Roundtree I'm just like I'm just gonna
keep going yeah Eric haters like bro I
tapped out
I even hit his mom up on our histogram I
was like hey I or idea I was like hey if
you have a towel just throw it from
wherever you're at mom see if it works
God it wasn't I watch it different and
we'll move on after I think those guys
should get a half-million it those guys
should become safer hmm but here's the
thing if you think a million people
bought in 80 bucks a pop if a million
people didn't buy a million people
didn't so maybe if 300,000 people paid
to watch and eighty bucks a pop then
you're looking at still that's twenty
twenty two million dollars so twenty two
million dollars then think of the ESPN
money that ESPN gives the UFC two ear
that pay-per-view right think of all the
sponsors so you know how the Octagon
looks like a NASCAR yeah
the fighters don't see any of that money
right and think of the Reebok gear that
they win if I don't see any of that
money Wow
so does the US other coaches do they pay
for the girls coaches no oh you're
kidding no the paint you get one coach
to fly to fly you and one coach to the
event Oh what can you do men entertain
man it hurts right yeah just yeah it
just feels wrong but it doesn't take
away from what those guys do out there
it doesn't take away from the fact that
they go out there and are champions but
yeah at that if that's the rates man
they should get a million bucks a pop
easy you know yeah but yeah
congratulations to all the fighters man
it made me it gave me a whole different
respect you know I went to actually went
to workout this morning there was a
couple times where I wanted to give up
today and I was like I'm gonna keep God
just thought of even just any of those
guys out there I was like damn even
Boston salmon dude named after a [ __ ]
great name yeah named after a [ __ ]
great name I was [ __ ] item a menu item
like Boston Market Boston Sam yeah think
about that dude just naming somebody off
of a [ __ ] menu item and he were
grilled cauliflower who's next
he worked out oh yeah yeah and the fee I
I just blew my mind man it was very
impressive sport but seeing it there
live it's way more intense and way more
violent my dad used to hold his breath
when that fight really yeah can hold his
breath for about 15 minutes is your dad
a shark he's a whale Oh is he all right
let's do this well underwater father huh
I could say
I can see it's still a mammal man oh
yeah man much more respect to you bro
don't [ __ ] touch me
let's hop out what a fella start with
some king under sting it this first one
comes from Jack under Koffler Jack under
Kaufman yo what's going on Theo Brandon
it's your boy Jack Gang Gang buzz buzz
buzz sorry I can't get her sting it I
used to be an uber driver and one thing
about being an uber driver is you have
the same [ __ ] conversation so when I
started doing to avoid that podcast just
slightly and worked really well but I
wanted to get you guys thoughts King and
our sting in conversations with you over
driver what a quality move great move
done with the Legoland people yelling
out buzz buzz yeah that's ridiculous
you can't run I think you're an
alcoholic dude what he thinks I'm a
giant bumblebee did you take your kid
yeah because you all seem like the kind
of dude that would be opposed that you
dress like you would get a leg of lamb
you say to me you like knowing [ __ ] Ryan
oh you don't see him bro I'll [ __ ]
fight you in independent carwash brewing
too son dude first of all Ober drivers I
find it annoying when they talked me
every time especially when I just wanna
chill if you like going to the airport
you know you got like a 30-minute Drive
you're like [ __ ] dude yeah you know it's
weird cuz sometimes that most of the
time I don't want to talk you know cuz I
just want to do some work I wanna do a
little meditation to talk for a living
right so yeah I'm just it's like dude I
just got out of a shitty conversation
with a guy who [ __ ] calls himself the
sting all over the guys please from a
[ __ ] 80s rock bath
yeah dude I'm from Louisiana I a CT and
he's never played a sport in his life
dude and I wasn't playing tennis by CT
bro dude I grew up yeah I just had an
hour to have a conversation with an 80s
rock so [ __ ] dude you're boring CT
when you when your mom was pregnant with
you she just [ __ ] roll down hills
oh whatever mama do cartwheels every
Monday to give you CT bro you have the
same DNA is shale okay you [ __ ] a
neverending story
hey really I went to UFC fighters became
a [ __ ] when the plant was walked out of
the Octagon whatever
what was the question dude always
excited you idiot and you can't actually
been there before you [ __ ] lot less
[ __ ] been there before and that's too
lot lizards already you idiot hashtag
and I'll say this though dude um the
whole time it's like an uber driver some
guy behind me just yelled the whole time
rat king the whole time never watch the
fights just trying to get my attention
finally broke turn around bro finally
the ninth fight n I turn around he's
like love you brother dude missed five
hours of fighting but there was a lot of
fans there man a lot of people yelling
Gang Gang buzz it was awesome I was in
the jungle gym like in this other dad
with his kids like you look like [ __ ]
Bromley thanks man buzz buzz my kid man
no look you got a roast Brendan when you
see him in the world um look Jack under
Kaufer which is also an old sex move of
mine the old jack under yeah I say no
chatting but here's the thing though if
you don't talk to him do you let do you
are you okay with them playing whatever
music they want to play yeah I like it
but sometimes every now and then I'll
get over driver especially when I travel
out of state that will drop some
[ __ ] knowledge on you really
here just me driving like on your right
is where actually the first I met and
they'll just go through all the city
ships
nope that's true last night I had to go
very rare that's very rare
yeah but that's so funny to hear from
his perspective that they get the same
conversation I don't even think about
that people probably getting us how's
your how's your day people say the same
thing it's like Groundhog say dude
people just say this what else
so what did we do he said King or sing
it right King under sing it
conversations uber driver staining it on
the next one guys this next one comes
from Andre of Mayo from Halifax no I
ain't gonna wear a condom are you here
and my question for you guys the king of
sting is artificial intelligence I
listen to Joe Rogan podcast so I've been
hearing him and you I must talk about it
and I just kind of think maybe we should
slow down fake news girl but I'd like to
hear you guys love the podcast let's
buzz Gang Gang she said by buzz first
yeah so tell it does love you Brendan
alright thank you
thank you good to see a girl good to see
call in AI were you at on this AI the
only hope for intelligence for Brendan
the only thing about AIS and her mom
wouldn't make you watch terminator yeah
that's probably true let me think
artificial intelligence I think I think
we should stop technology I think we
have enough right now we're like we're
letting robots and battery-powered and
electric powered things like like over
like overcome the value of you being a
human oh you know it's too much man yeah
it's too much what's the goal what's
next you you want to build robots so
that we just get rid of humans yeah at
all robot world that's the Terminator
plot hey Siri will you turn my phone off
listen it says no bra well should I
understand Ebonics so that's cool
hey Siri we signing off well your phone
doesn't work so you don't have that
either so yo this is a yawn oh that's a
that's the Sam's Android that's an
Android here's the other thing about AI
and artificial intelligence and when
people are like we're in a simulation
people who say we're in a simulation are
only rich people only rich people are
people are doing well watching a
simulation man it's crazy thing yeah you
don't have anyone working at me Tom's
going
bro we're in a simulation like they're
not making [ __ ] Big Macs and [ __ ]
McNuggets going you know this is cool
man we're in a simulation it's all good
baby like broken blood saying they don't
think it's a simulate that's not true I
was at a I was outside of Natchez
Mississippi one time and I was at a
McDonald's and they had a fella and he
said it's a black gentleman work around
the county said Hebert when a simulation
watch this and he took a McRib and threw
it at the back of a kind of rubenesque
woman who was walking out to the play
area who smoked and he goes this lady's
gonna get pissed watch this and he
[ __ ] threw it lady
she got [ __ ] pissed called it he
called it that's a [ __ ] that's a
psychic oh that's no Babe Ruth the
[ __ ] bad food right that's that McRib
psychic oh dude it ain't nothing like a
McRib either that's how you know AI it's
[ __ ] real well that's the thing too
it's like and they tempt a lot of the
urban community to make rib is back the
McRib oh my god you're talking about the
jello shaped as a [ __ ] rib yeah it's
a [ __ ] more than is not think about
it and I'm up the snot you molded into a
[ __ ] River oh it's not the Houston
barbecue sauce the Eric what do you
think about the McRib make Rio harbor
breath yeah they make fish they don't
like it what do you mean they yeah yeah
what huh yeah what do you think they
make fish well she loves it Wow either
change event people change people change
it that's that see it's like a melting
pot in here it is that's two white guys
when I said make make make fillet they
went oh yeah it's called a Mick fish
Mick fillet is it pretty sure ah that's
a combo look at it teamwork makes the
dream work
don't what else we got [ __ ] King this
girl King AI
[ __ ] they know sting artificial
intelligence dude doing tremendous
intelligence any more real intelligence
some what people think this flat earth
next one coming with your big bro
you do know you dress like you just
found out the earth is round
first of all flat earth let's be honest
came out of the urban community dude and
I'll say that think dude the first I've
ever heard of it
crazy white guy came up with not a jam
then probably Irving meant that sounds
good no black you will have insane
hammers that I know dude laughs people
four years ago yes I was at a pizza
place was around midnight Peter the
black guys sat me down and said hey man
we got something to tell you you know
and I thought they'd [ __ ] kidnap my
girl now that there's like rap well oh
yeah but but it was they said hey man
flat earth and I sat there for 40
minutes and danced about it well at
first I thought Flat Earth it was like a
new rapper and then Mick little Mick
flatter
little flatter flatter well by Dan by
the N bro I believed them I bought into
it I make sense it's like the maze not a
sense yeah Mason ring you went to only
to fourth grade yeah I can't do me ought
to slap the [ __ ] out of him boys went
around oh you're real round
you're a real grade master dude nobody
believed you reduce great master if
they're called degrees bro [ __ ]
miss Vaughn our next one is coming from
a body Hinds body hi body hi body shout
to the Chop same gang buzz buzz buzz
buzz dawg Brandon Theo Chabot D here in
Oklahoma City come and actually with a
king in steam mm-hmm [ __ ] in public
and I'm not talking about I feel I'm not
talking about going on going in a bush
and taking a [ __ ] or on the side of the
street
talking about Walmart McDonald's all
that [ __ ] I'm in telling like that for
me I can't do it I don't know what it is
I don't know if it's a Todd Lee don't
know bro but any time I go in and I can
smell the ass of the person before me
just call it [ __ ] called rough ride
can't do it man so really should wait to
see what you guys have to say about it I
love you both you know all your podcasts
anytime they drop on you know in my ears
so I love you guys appreciate what you
guys are doing keep it up and
Gang Gang buzz buzz buzz Thank You bear
oh sorry
nice guy Bodi and I appreciate that and
also Derek called you body let's start
there there bro
how did you spell it Bo DHI now I'm
regretting how I said it now ah shooting
in public restaurants we out on this
well look man it depends dude I think if
you can stand and do it there's that
kind of Polynesian kind of style where
you can like put your stand on the sumo
squat yeah if you can do that with your
feet on the things like frog yeah in
Africa if you go to Africa you go to
South Africa they just have like a hole
in the rounding to squat over pretty
calm and chill but [ __ ] I don't I
wouldn't recommend [ __ ] in a train
station downtown Tucson or any Dunkin
Donuts something got on the back of my
legs there from the toilet seat it have
one of those steel toilet seats it's
like the floor just turns into the
toilet yeah I don't you talk about
there's no and one yeah it's a song the
whole building is this all the one the
walls turning into the floor turns into
the toilet turns into the devil this is
Asian bro oh dude and there was um yeah
there was a lot of miss like mystic
writing and stuff on the wall but I got
us some severe burns on the back of my
legs from sitting the type of dude that
writes on bathroom walls I've done that
know anyone who writes on bathroom walls
yeah bro people over time history
hieroglyphics
dude when you're on you're on yeah I you
know sometimes you got a [ __ ] you got a
[ __ ] man I'm no doubt about that
I just gotta you know but I'm not scared
to do it what I'm saying I don't care
sometimes you gotta be a little you know
be a little hesitant if you're [ __ ]
in the club if you're [ __ ] man KFC a
Waffle House a game like a UFC fight
because you might get in there with the
wrong crowd yeah and then under they'll
do this this is tap and that means they
down the suck you off dropping turds and
sucking dick yeah there's certain it's
Morse code
it's Morse code though for what I'm
trying to help you out tonight or cut
your mores form or what we nerds yeah
bro the favorites to foot it means come
to my stop it's one foot come I'll come
to yours
what is Morse code bro so I'm all I'm
saying if you're gonna drop trou in
public
places know the rules bro don't get mad
when your dick skins sucked when you
drop down low because if you engage in
that sort of what you're out here Bremen
how many dudes have tried to [ __ ] you
with a bunch yeah I'm fending them off
it's my training for the u.s. just
slapping dicks like this [ __ ] oh my
god you're going to hell live a little
man yeah well you're gonna be living in
hell bucko well I'd [ __ ] king chicken
on in public places buddy I gotta go you
gotta go
planes I don't give a [ __ ] yeah
oh I won't [ __ ] on a plane and go my
high dump I know well what's up baby I
know well enough to [ __ ] before the
plane leaves or then or then defecate
after the plane lands I'm not one of
those weirdos just cuz I'm in the air
for three hours means I have to go
defecate you know and I've [ __ ] dude I
used to [ __ ] outside and I used to bury
this guy's [ __ ] for a long time in his
yard when I was a kid if I'm flying
spirit because it's so insulting the
shitty seats they give you in service I
just blow up those bathrooms just for
the [ __ ] of it Wow
yeah suck it spirit it's hard to in
South West for that matter I I don't
like doing number twos in the air
because it just seems like it's just
against God I feel like it doesn't feel
natural I'll give you that yeah you
shouldn't be doing Dookie while you're
flying at 300 miles an hour 300 in the
air yeah how fast do you think planes go
this is gonna be great 600 miles an hour
Wow unbelievable man we look it up I bet
it's four to four now you just said 300
300 yeah and I might have not known oh
you were pretty close 500 seven mile 575
miles an hour oh wow
seems like someone has an education here
uh go on to the next one Wow
King Jigme here 11 episodes I'm gonna
say king of man also the big move is is
doing that uh that
that that Clint Eastwood is when you
know door on the stall and you shed at a
place ooh that's you talk about that
country-western huh oh yeah see again
you're asking for trouble men really
yeah code no that's that freaking old
school that's that freaking Johnny
splash baby when you [ __ ] take the
door off a stall and take a dump there
John Wayne Wayne that's that wild boy
yeah that's that [ __ ] yeah it's not
for me man
well you know support the podcast here's
an ad you know deal when you're selling
online getting your orders can be a real
pain dude it's time-consuming it costs a
ton of money and so many carriers you
choose from you know what you're gonna
do you know what the best choice is you
know what king of things gonna use when
our merch drops next week yep I know
exactly where we use ship station
correct it's the fastest easiest most
affordable way to manage and ship your
orders like King and the sting merch
jerseys
don't touch me shirts the white king a
Singh shirts we got it all dude yep
ship station helps you get orders out
quickly save money on shipping costs and
keep your customers happy remember the
old days when you had to ship something
you had to give it to you no Kevin
Costner order Paul Revere put on a boat
that's over days are over no matter what
you're selling they got you gas station
works with all of the major carriers
including USPS FedEx UPS berth storks
even Amazon Fulfillment so you can
compare and choose the best shipping
solutions for you and your customer get
it done the best way they offer big
discounts on shipping costs for any
business same postage discounts for the
big businesses as the small businesses
so don't think oh you know they're
selling you know a thousand salami x' or
whatever they're doing better to me I'm
peddling a couple of freaking you know
brake pads over here at Donny's break
don't worry about nope same shipping
costs for both people
no wonder ship station the number one
choice of online sellers man nobody
that's crazy
I quit wondering just a minute ago yeah
you'll ship more and less time with the
best rates available and right now King
and the sting listeners can try ship
station free for 60 days when you
use promo code cat and that's the cats
with a cake k 80s yep how Brendan
naturally spells it cats with a K
there's absolutely no risk you can start
your free trial without even entering
your credit card info
just visit shipstation comm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in cats that's K 80s that
shipstation calm then enter promo code
cats shipstation calm make ship happen
some got spayed for teals haircut
alright next we got relationship advice
yeah at first we got Valerie from
Houston Texas how she sounds pretty in
college has never been in a relationship
damn girl super version how do I get a
boyfriend gang game
buzz-buzz girl she said she's super rude
she's a virgin no super virgin super
like like she doesn't have she had never
had a boyfriend she's a nothing got you
cute girl
yeah go ahead deal I don't know when
this when 19 years old
um late teens up that old no notes I I
need more info do we have any more info
she's not that old what do you mean mean
like 19 alright so you haven't kissed a
boy I had a girl fall good baby
I thought you were saying like it's too
like Oh 19 not that old like you know um
yeah Houston she a cougar let's see she
didn't say what college she went to but
actually definitely in college any other
info she said should be a cool homey to
chill with when she's asked you board
that man and what are you Derek what do
you got what do you think of it a you're
predator I mean she's cute she needs to
just go outside and just talk to a dude
go to a library talk to one of the nerdy
dudes come on their pants talking on
this girl look at her you know nerdy
dudes can [ __ ] - yeah The Grateful type
they put it down no jacking off so much
thinking of a girl so finally when they
get there they ready really you think
they put in the work row no nerdy dude
how singular they know what they're
doing they plan ahead they're they're
really they're plotters I think you got
something you're talking about some you
know bro Havas witnesses over there -
skeet and then everybody's
confront you talking about frat boy yeah
I'm talking about those [ __ ] library
hitters good people great people doing
in the XML system yeah
[ __ ] oh dude Harry Potter bust nut dude
and who wouldn't yeah dude bro I will be
dick in that mouth I put it in Hermione
bro you know what I'm saying yeah let's
go to cat cuz we have a female
representative in here cat would you
give her the mic what suggestion would
you have for this young lady you're 19
years old these are the best ho years of
your life you got like about five to
seven good years of just getting dick
down from oh wow damn yeah I like that
but the nerdy guys are the way to go or
guys who used to be chubby because
they're just kind of thankful to be
there where should she go you think
she's you're like a pizza and ass all
the guys run a train on her or something
no just hang out with them go
baskin-robbins and get DP'd some dope
nerdy dudes or a guy who used to be
chubby cuz they're kind of
self-conscious they're happy for the
attention just want to give what about a
tinder what's that line me up too old
for tinder I don't know even on there
cuz she's gone ten do I get dick down or
no yeah you get dick town anywhere
digging down is a nice time
hey who brought the old guy Jesus Christ
man she's 19 no it doesn't she just
wants dick Thank You cat I respect your
views woman's perspective there yeah and
we needed it and apparently there's a
couple of good years of hoeing out there
if you want to be doing that or if you
wanna you can join the church you can
join the Peace Corps you know I'm saying
a [ __ ] guy on a beach somewhere you
know in another country you could you
know could or go to the Waffle House and
get homies ride a train on okay well
mixed okay no one asked for advice from
us then ladies I would okay I got from
all angles oh you got the female you got
the black dude he's not the one got him
they're in the build it's it's kind of a
the light someone good luck girl you
seem cool as [ __ ] though yeah you seem
like a very sweet girl dude what you
need to do is like scroll through the
comments on our page and see some other
dude who's like oh this is dope I'm an H
Town bike you listen King this thing and
then [ __ ] go on a date and talk about
it
yeah these guys are [ __ ] think about
actually you know what we will play a
little bit of love connectors if you
want to send a DM to the king in the
sting Instagram why you should go out
with that girl right then we can tag you
in in this video whenever we put it up
on the king of the see Instagram and
you've trust me you'll probably have a
lot of serious dirt balls and h-town YN
women that would love to meet you yes we
can do that though we can do it - that's
a great knocking in well though well
this ends in a lawsuit or a death what
dude you never there's some creeps out
there bro I want no liability on this
well you just said it was a good idea
wow do you even live inside of yourself
yeah dude I'm saying there's pros and
cons sent up strangers dude my advice
was to go to a [ __ ] subway and get a
[ __ ] train ran on it yeah don't
listen to me look go get that look
here's what I say put a rope around your
neck and go get that justice smaller at
the subway the two brothers to show up
and train you down you know more that
for shoulr express didn't Magga yeah
alright up next we got Jefferson Ollie
from Westminster Colorado Jefferson
Ollie from Westminster hey Brandon Theo
this Jefferson Alley from Westminster
Colorado wearing this really green ass
shirt here because I'm about to go play
some softball out here in Broomfield
gang shut up the broom jockeys
representing today for a little
relationship advice but dating this girl
for about a month so it's all fresh
she's a white girl hmm usually that's
not significant but this case it is she
has been shown a little
racial tendencies lately saying some
things that got me questioned her
motives in life
in that area something about me you you
can't tell that I'm a quarter Mexican I
got that Canelo thing freckles quite
honest but nuanced you know low English
no importa quad oh wow
see see any of you don't know what I
just said that's your girl I know do
with that Nicaraguan in New York and of
the same man but a gang just wondering
if I should you know let things come to
a head at some point where we just
discover she's races when she meets my
mom and my grandma or something like
that or maybe I should bring it up to
her like a girl what he what are your
views on this stuff cuz you know I got
that I got that Mexican blood in me you
know you can't tell and we got to part
ways if you got some you got some beef
with that so okay wonder what your views
are now an ass out with it no you know
it's fresh free relationship right now
so I don't want to go too far with it
then discover some [ __ ] later on so yeah
you never know gang buzzbuzz buzzbuzz
homie keep it up man also dude probably
ditch the races huh do what I would do
is I would [ __ ] get some type of tea
and just costing her [ __ ] eyes and
say beat it nerd who [ __ ] with racism
oh you know I'm saying well she a lady
he said he's not sure he said he thinks
a lady might be a rough sea state dude
here's the thing if you're even
borderline like man is she races she
racist yeah there's no borderline if
she's stolen hints out like if she's
watching the news no yeah I think they
should build that wall [ __ ] these hoes
you know yeah he's all about it
you got a racist one yeah I think it's
interesting I mean he's he's also he's
that hide and go see em pre you know
yeah it's time I don't know what siempre
means but I know that he you know that's
so he's really got that surprise he
almost looks like uh he looks lighter
than we do
he looks like Andrew Santino you know
what I'm sayin bro he's got a Rio he's
got that unique style yeah so she might
have been leaning for a white dude and
he threw a curveball right so maybe
she's just like dude I wasn't expect to
be redhead Mexican she might be trying
to invite him to a damn clue clucks
quinceanera
yeah so anything's possible but yeah I
think I wouldn't hold it against her
like she had this weird motive
went on in the background like you're
kind of baiting her like you just keep
driving her up and down Cesar Chavez
Highway and [ __ ] like that
everywhere you know invited icon Sierra
you have a [ __ ] Fiesta yeah and then
[ __ ] just make all the spicy food and
see how she reacts yeah I think you can
do that you could um you know or watch
Breaking Bad and see how she reacts to
some of the later seasons it's not a bad
idea
see see if she wants to watch American
History X first on that flick yeah and
I'm saying like see what her choices are
is Django her favorite movie
yeah what are we doing yeah but Django
that's not Mexican I know what's racist
you're right though like it's a really
hard to capture and we got problems
yeah yeah I think man if you're worried
about it it shall be pissed at the end
of American History X we got problems
but I think it's also you could talk to
her about it and see what's going on she
may maybe she got jumped by some guys
maybe she got attacked you know you
never know where some of her eggs could
be coming from the checkpoint
um but yeah but if at that point she's
just lobbing just you know racial bombs
yeah s you know the S word you know I
don't know or you know other racial
slurs Mexican slur there's not that many
for them yeah that would drive them
crazy
is there any words that would draw it
like offend you rotten like redneck I
don't like when people call me redneck
trigger for you yeah it is man I realize
I don't mind it I just don't like it
when it's like derogative somebody's
joking little redneck I don't really use
redneck I don't assume I don't I don't
think redneck when I think it because
the reason I don't like it is cuz it's
too simple of a way to classify me it's
like just come a little come with a
little more yeah but look everybody's
different I don't know man yeah I when
you come to a cracker
I like cracker I like crackers - funny
honkies fun dude I love honky I don't
see you know I'd be part of the of a
group thought we had one yeah we ain't
missing
[Laughter]
but I think it's interesting I think
it's cool you're thinking about this
kind of stuff man and yeah I think just
to see where her heart set may be and
also it could be an opportunity to kind
of learn a little bit see what she see
where she's coming from but also I need
to know how racist she is scale one to
ten if she's an eight kick rocks [ __ ]
yeah yeah if she's an eight slap around
like a pinata
yeah look some good things come with a
little bit of racism it's fun good food
curveball yeah you get you go to a
racist city in America best food the
Baltimore Chicago Texas yeah just the
state Texas seems dark when you've been
in Texas bro that they have the best
barbecue racist barbecue okay I guess
that's true they might have some yeah
anybody have some good old-school
recipes but yeah Baltimore New Orleans
Chicago anywhere you can catch a bullet
you can get a good on me like the best
meal yeah yep but windy a man which is
could I see a luck
all right boys up next we got debate
club first up is Reuben from London
Reuben from that is me I maybe that's
the your English brother over there dude
and let's just like me you guys look
pretty similar oh it's my mom I was mom
I'm not a bull Todd he shaves it a
little extra on the sides though that
guy straight Trilly Eliot right there
that dudes trill as hell bro um so he's
saying after a night out with a random
girl your place are her place God ah
usually her place so I can skip the [ __ ]
out you know I'm saying she's got yours
then I come up with let's say just it's
a one-night hookup you know come up with
a line why she needs to leave like you
feel bad about yourself
cuz that her place I do not barely I'm
out go home take a [ __ ] I can never saw
will never sleep at someone's place or
I'll let them sleep at my place so I'm
not going to ever probably be married
you have a problem with it oh I can't do
it you never stay the night over any of
your friends house growing up
yeah I did it I'll wet the bed all the
time and then I have to get up in the
middle of the night Oh neat around in
the dark and find their washer dryer oh
my god dude one time couldn't find the
dryer I had to clean the sheets and then
they had like a lamp and I had to like
hold the sheet really close to the bulb
for like two hours and just move it or
mostly it would dry but I would do the
heat off the light bulb but I don't know
what if I stay at a friend's house and I
pissed I was also Pete if I pissed the
bed as a kid
yeah or leaked out of your brain Yohan
either/or but if I was leaking my piss
at a friend's house what I'd do I bet
God [ __ ] I wet the bed I'd get up get a
big glass of water and pretend I drop
the water everywhere yeah everybody
believes that dream well the present kid
I thought I did I was for you [ __ ] but
as a kid you're like oh they don't know
but they just played along with it now
that I'm older they definitely know they
know definitely know like Auburn is
drinking a yellow water again what a
crazy guy huh so like pee pee ah
definitely staying at their place done
but going to their place is exciting
it's neat to see what's going on you
know immediately different smells yeah
what their vibe is you know real dirty
oh yeah oh dude I'm recording this
girl's place one time it was disgusting
bro and I was like oh could you put up
with some [ __ ] but I rode used to hook
up with some girl really in a room Isaak
yeah I like roaches really she was that
hot I'm actually like roaches like that
shoes do you mind my son not at all
Wow yeah then I throw it down with your
disgust and I'm out of here
oh god what an [ __ ] yeah I would stay
in hell I mean the place up you wouldn't
do [ __ ] I would do [ __ ] whatever help
them clean it up dude are you into their
house well we'd let you in the [ __ ]
house bro you're dressed like them but
you dress like a bag like a backup
catcher from league of their own today
we are members of the all-american
League we come from
I say there's I say there's their house
yeah 62% of people say at her place yeah
that's a fun like kind of game to play
what's going on we'll get a steal
up next we got a question from Mike
Domingue Mike Domingue hey what's up
Theo Brennan
my name's Mike demonstrable Mahon
abrasca first of all Theo thank you very
much for your podcast and everything you
do comedy wise I got 60 days sober gang
brother you that's cool man you through
all those kind of tough days cuz
yourself main ngratulations humble dude
man from watching you on UFC 2 what
you're doing now love you both
I got a debate club for you rap music
the melodies now you've got the mumble
rap versus the more lyrical rap are we
liking that good but what get it what
are we like in the Bubba defended the
Devon - Devon - Devon - Devon a bus
coming - Debra - Robert about the duh
yeah but but but about said what say
yeah - Bay Club holic gang respect no
this is rap he does know his rap man and
thanks for the kind words brother um
what do you think Derrick cuz I've come
in let's say a spherical man I don't
need no 17 year old [ __ ] Nam Huynh to
me they got them though they catch they
get them hooks the [ __ ] hooks banging
Kanye's in on it yeah you're such a
[ __ ] ho I love it you ever heard that
song it's a very positive music you're
such a [ __ ] home oh my bad Tony
Robbins get the [ __ ] out of you it's
just fun to listen to
I don't go to [ __ ] JZ for motivation
I don't need [ __ ] Naz to drop a
lyrics on me so I get my life together
I don't need Bubba Sparxxx advice on
financial planning
[Laughter]
Paul whoa baby that's a really good
point man you're right apparently I'm
one of the wrong places for the wrong
thing is dude I I did just download that
new steet that some old Steve Irwin
though remember Crocodile Hunter what
are you talking about dude the [ __ ]
white rapper okay I got him yeah I
remember him
no I know the Crocodile Hunter Steve
Irwin yeah if you look at him just as
that bro if you but if you play as
[ __ ] lyrics don't be about crocodiles
yeah I know that's a remit alright yeah
all right
that [ __ ] derp as Steve Irwin we make
sigh I like the lyrics just guys know
that everyone's this is a thing get your
own [ __ ] everyone's little easy little
yadi little yah-tchi
yeah [ __ ] Mariotti yeah [ __ ]
little homeschool yeah bro yeah a little
prisoner there was one another guy get
your [ __ ] haha yeah it just never ends
Doolittle law who is the one guy let me
get face tattoos and dye their hair yeah
a little pill or whatever a little
deceased what was that guy's name little
punk little pump yeah pumping yeah a
little bit of life left a lot of others
have pills all they read butters and
pills and sadness get your [ __ ] life
together fellas well I would love to see
some new like it is interesting how rap
gets kind of narrow it's like his only
you can only rap about like your well to
your car I guess it's everything though
maybe almost in a j.cole though you want
pure lyrics yeah listen Jay cool I like
that new yellow wolf is out dude there's
pretty Wow
but I'd like to see something new I like
tres Oh
when Rae sremmurd came out brother they
had some [ __ ] their [ __ ] was kind of
a new vibe I still hold on I said Jay
call you it yeah I like yellow get out
really get out yellow wolf brah
get out Jake whole yellow wolf
Jay Cole the shoe designer never heard
of him
dude Jay Cole is that an alias for
something never - Jay Cole bro don't
listen to some [ __ ] yellow wall -
dude trunk music volume three bro Trump
music [ __ ] right thanks for reaching
out there brother it's a good question a
lot of this new rap it's like people
mumbling you're not even talking anymore
I wonder how sneezing and they really
did a remix to it want to yeah I may
want to create a beat out of yeah some
guys in a coma
that's the new guy little coma this
record a [ __ ] preschool class then
turn the [ __ ] beat in dude yeah dude
bro it's not want to see some of the
hard hitters but I think this is the
time when we get that rebirth man
congratulations on on whatever you got
today 62 days probably homework 83%
people say lyrical come on this next one
is from her nickname is one time parem
Parma Gianna I think I mean ston
parmesan Thomas Capitan oh come on time
Palmer John what's up to you and Brendan
this is Tom from book in New York so I
had a question for you guys Caucasian
Club so I'm half chinese and half
Italian gang but no over women which are
better Chinese or Italian thanks guys
all the best
buzz buzz dawg so he's saying either
Italian or Chinese women huh that's what
he's saying Chinese are Italian women
you're been with a Chinese woman yeah I
don't know man me neither
I don't know what they look like I
wonder what they look like they look
like Chinese people have no idea I just
I don't know well we can ask at that I
find that pad racist but let's ask I
don't she knows way better than we do
you don't even know
who they are yeah you helped our friend
learn a little bit you'll see over
China's at what do you want to know yeah
nothing I don't want to know anything
he's asking if China Chinese women or
Italians are better she wouldn't know I
know he's trying to pick one though yeah
talk you sir best ask a Chinese dude or
a [ __ ] Italian dude we're neither
thank you cats but if I have to guess if
I'm just [ __ ] guessing yeah probably
with Italian bird I'm pretty sexy I like
the language way better your Brown a
Chinese person we have to get somewhere
very rude they push people especially in
buses terrible drivers or change mmm and
they'll eat the run yes I was in China
God dies and make a soup everybody's
lunch they move on yes China is full
word thinking they're not then I throw a
[ __ ] they don't sound for emotions know
there's sardines they just [ __ ] go
and push people out of the way Alan's
not so much they're [ __ ] melting
cheese on each other's back hair and
[ __ ] fist fighting on the internet
photo Italians are the kind of people I
know an Italian guy he bought a boxing
ring and he Duty one price is right one
the money what a boxing ring backyard
Jersey [ __ ] yeah on believable and they
make delicious meatballs on itself oh
don't [ __ ] take your Little Caesars
the Moose Jaw that's waiter than Chinese
oh the Chinese oh [ __ ]
unless I make you orange chicken now
talking well that's the thing when it
comes to the food it's it's Italian all
day but 50/50 or a nice slices extra
good point it's uh it's about ninety
four six get a nice slice of margherita
pizza get your dick yeah I go Italian I
like the long fingernails I like the
propensity while you're sleeping the
woman could [ __ ] kill you or cut you
through yeah I sleep well around that
for some reason I'm going to tell the
Italian 76% say Italian as well it's too
easy all right
I gotta leave in a little bit next one
it's like what you're in the episode -
the kid - be kid hey its a man babby a
big club for you guys get Buster school
life versus home lunch
I'll tell right now AC in the car though
thing buzz buzz crank that ACL brothers
no reason be dripping sweat now in the
car
Annie did sting sting buzz buzz which is
- - buzzes basically - buzz so this is
your question then this guy loves you uh
school lunch for us home lunch it's a
great question depends on your mom cuz
it feels miles make it probably go to my
mom's lunch you know I'm saying she
didn't want to feed you
yeah mom she gave us a bag and I have
nothing in it's another little trick bag
your mom said use your memory yeah use
your imagination there's nothing in
there what you used to have yeah [ __ ] I
probably say homeless school lunch with
some [ __ ] where I went shout to
Virginia Court Elementary the Tigers
yeah
horrible lunches so my mom packed me a
nice I dude I had fruit by the foot
I had Little Debbie [ __ ] oatmeal Pie
Wow I had [ __ ] liar babies go [ __ ]
look at me I dunkaroo look I look like a
who carries dunkaroos in his pocket at
all times I petty graham anything
[ __ ] good never have the low
calorie meal of noting that my mother
gave me mom did you ear you know what
you need to eat knowledge you know
knowledge I liked it I liked the school
lunch man I liked being a part of the
team I like seeing the ladies with the
plastic mitts on I like seeing the hair
I like meeting the ladies the lady
across the street and he was our lunch
lady and then her grandson killed her
but I like that whole lunchroom Bob I
like going in there with the hot steam
in the air and a [ __ ] you don't know
what's coming could be a pair for Sam
and you just see a [ __ ] old
liver-spotted on ya and just drop a
scoop a [ __ ] ho right on your skin
would be just fat oh yeah saggy belly Oh
beautiful and I love the burgers and
those round pizzas and the milk you
[ __ ] put the little bag in there got
the strawberry milk bro I never had
strawberry milk you really did yeah huh
yeah just had why I had white male races
sometimes it was sour and it was all
sour and everybody just drank sour milk
and you got that little knife or with
that orange straw popping [ __ ] this
game of thrones that [ __ ] dude
then you take one of the [ __ ] kids
and just [ __ ] put it right in his
neck - oh wow how about prison yeah
that's not no one had that I love school
lunch man and I'd eat him again if they
serve come on school lunch now - yeah
remember the square pizza Oh bro the
square or the peanut butter jelly and
they just load it up with peanut butter
yeah [ __ ] two inches of peanut butter
baby a whole one time give me a whole
tray of [ __ ] peanut butter that was
it dude that was alternate grilled
cheese I guess that's lunch but I'll
take it wasn't that good but it was okay
I was happy for it yeah community and I
remember the burgers the buns had like a
little bit of chalk dust on them yeah
yeah and if we get on your hands the
wheat once you like I'll be honest I
love the sloppy joes they were good man
gang 77% of people say home lunch okay
depends where you won't have to wrap it
up soon yes well more done you want to
do a fun one for my honor one rip my
drip do you guys want to do all you call
let's do you call it B let's do one font
my own
you got time for one yeah saying I'll
pick this one she's the best one
this is Aunt Becky oh [ __ ] swaggy GPG
her name chief name is baby
she refuses to watch any movie that
shows or resembles Barack Obama's
president it's her fun fact she is there
a movie like that yeah every Morgan
Freeman movie yeah come on she uh she's
currently looking for a man and she also
takes her dog everywhere she goes I'd
rather push the 19 year old it's a tough
sell can we zoom in on some of this uh
some of Aunt Becky and what's going to
country life girls kick ass your life
drinks girls get darker dirtier dirtier
Oh Aunt Becky a freak and then what's
that say all gave some old gave someone
died she put a sticker on the back of
her truck all gave some some gave all so
a la finca she's right there by that la
finca Mexican restaurant I know well
she's definitely going there cuz she's
races oh and she bought the pet care too
they got then in the back you can see
vulture pet care a value pet care value
what's this logo here what's this on the
truck US Army and Alward ahem yeah
what's that this is a warning do not
screw with my Jeep and shows her killing
someone you know what I don't know she
wants a man yeah I think she's trying to
scare everybody off yeah it seems very
alarming she has the dog with her at all
times
support our troops Jeep girls do it
dirty girls kick ass I don't think she
wants a man think she wants a woman hmm
she's flaunting she's definitely flexi
out there oh my god he's not afraid to
post up against the Jeep I like her her
posture there yes she definitely looks
like she will Spring Break forever until
her [ __ ] nipples just fall right off
over the ends of her teeth I think
someone needs to tell her spring break
is over she's no longer on spring break
in 2019 three weeks never over Frant
Becky dude average is a dog she's a Jeep
she has a bumper sticker polisher
definitely from MTV Spring Break she
definitely has at one time she went she
definitely has a little bit of Sinbad's
comb in her purse you know what I'm
saying bro she's the kind of lady that's
been you know she definitely has a big
tattoo of downtown Debbie Brown or
whatever on her back right a seven Magga
hats and her [ __ ] back seat I don't
watch a movie that reminds her of a
[ __ ] Obama but what good movies the
Obama in dude a few which one maybe the
warmer you did a basketball bracket and
pick North Carolina I can't remember
anything else he even did know he's done
some good movies really he was good at
intently basketball Redemption he was
read in chambers was it yeah yeah people
should know that he was in Space Jam
well I mean let's all get it political I
think yeah look the other could be I
mean Obama undeniable extremely
inspirational president she doesn't like
that she doesn't I don't know what
movies and what is he in [ __ ] the
he's in demolition man - Jesus Christ
yeah well no wonder we were getting it
you know it's the cell of some stuff on
the current if he's inviting actor you
know I know he was in like a Gaul I knew
he's gonna Instagram with Mike Epps a
lot that's a lot of basketball yeah so I
thought he's in space Jim but I'm not
sure look Aunt Becky and bake Aunt Becky
needs to calm down Aunt Becky needs to
calm down a little shake yeah you're not
on spring break it's summer it's not
summer though you know but take a summer
break I think take it but just take a
break from what everything you're doing
but definitely a hottie I know a lot of
thick 16 year old dudes that would bang
this lady out
and I did also [ __ ] your Jeep like just
just people have sex with cars I don't
know I don't know about that I gotta go
I gotta go too
yeah you did good luck getting Becky
that's here bro we did it man get out of
here man nice to meet a UFC fighter man
I never I never really put it all
together yeah nice to meet one dude God
what about when they closed the gating
you have to stay in there do you have to
stay in you could jump out but then you
think waiver that man for the rest of
you yeah but still it wouldn't be here's
a guy who ran the entire time I ran the
entire time yeah it's a weird sport man
I don't think I'm not doing more spin
you're not do anymore I'm in Arizona
next week man Phoenix Friday Saturday
Oh live baby stand-up live Phoenix
Arizona great club man and I'll be in a
West Palm Beach next weekend also a
great club great club yeah I'm excited
man happy Easter to everybody Happy
Passover you know all the Cabrio you can
do man oh my favorite get that
suppository dude I [ __ ] just do it
I'll just hold your butt open and just
pour chocolate into it dude you know
what I'm saying [ __ ] yeah yeah I dunno
what you're saying man finally I do yeah
jam some peeps up your ass yeah live a
little
dude that's a no Sam right hi two
[ __ ] uh hi - snickering your sister
you feel me all right all right we under
like that all right the Lord's Day
enjoy